So, da sind wir am Start.
Es dauert noch, ähm, mal gucken.
Es dauert noch eine halbe Stunde ungefähr, dann geht's los.
Wir müssen noch mal kurz schauen, wie wir uns den Stream überhaupt angucken.
Ähm, also ich denke mal, am besten dürften wir über VLC sein.
Ja, das müsste qualimäßig ziemlich gut sein.
Ich guck mir das gerade mal in der Vorschau an.
Ja, das sieht gut aus.
Kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Wenn jetzt noch, also mal gucken, wie das ist, wenn das Sound losgeht.
Ob das passt, ah, das wird schon passen.
Das, das passt schon.
Erinnert mich mal dran, dass ich den Chat ausblenden will und die Musik ausmache, sobald's losgeht.
Wie hast du das mit VLC gemacht?
Ähm, Moment, zeig ich dir.
Du installierst dir Streamlink.
Das da.
Beziehungsweise lädst du dir das Binary runter.
Und dann startest du Streamlink.
Und Streamlink extrahiert quasi aus Twitch den, den Stream und öffnet's mit VLC.
Das ist praktisch.
Ich will aber kein Anstiften dazu, das zu machen.
Denn, ähm, ich geh mal davon aus, damit umgeht man auch die Werbung.
.
Und wenn ihr jemand gern guckt, spricht ja nix dagegen, den auch sobald's wie's geht zu unterstützen.
Wenn euch das ganze gefällt.
Mich kann man übrigens nirgendswo unterstützen, ich hab ja nix.
Doch ihr könnt mir, könnt mir für Paypal donaten.
Ähm, aber ich hab ja keinen Sub-Button, keinen Patreon-Account, keinen sonstwas.
Ihr könnt höchstens über meine Amazon-Rev-Links irgendwas kaufen.
Aber.
Ich bin ja da auch überhaupt nicht scharf drauf.
Moin, der Nilsson ist auch am Start.
So, was machen wir denn jetzt noch?
Eine halbe Stunde bevor es losgeht.
Wir schauen uns PC Master Race Memes an.
Was hat das Ibaro da geschickt?
Oh je, was ist das?
Was ist ein kreativer Titel?
Über Battlefield spekulieren.
Achso, ja, die Bingo-Karte, die kann ich euch zeigen, ja.
Die zeige ich euch.
Und ich restream, also, naja, was heißt restreamen?
Ich greife den von Twitch ab, also ich kriege von EA keinen Stream oder sowas.
Das wäre es ja auch noch.
Ja, also ich restream das.
Nee, nee, du musst den Stream nicht selbst aufmachen.
Wir gucken uns den an, wir gucken uns den zusammen an, hier, da.
Wow, es geht schon los.
Da können wir uns mal gucken, wie die Lautstärke ist.
Willst du die Lautstärke? Bisschen laut, oder?
Ich würde sagen, ich bin so froh, dass du das mitgebracht hast, weil ich mit dir gesprochen habe, also ich werde dich in die Fan-Familie senden.
Ich gehe in die Fan-Familie.
Du gehst.
Ich gehe.
Ich schaue dich in ein bisschen.
Okay, gut.
Okay, ihr Jungs, also, wie ich schon erwähnt habe, haben wir viele Leute, die hier in Hollywood eingeladen sind.
Okay, das Geschwätz müssen wir uns noch nicht angucken, oder?
Das ist im Endeffekt ja auch nur Leute, die keinen Plan haben, die interviewt werden jetzt.
Die beziehungsweise genauso wenig Plan haben wie wir.
So, ähm, was wollte ich zeigen?
Ach ja, das Bullshit.
Bullshit-Bingo-Board.
Also, ich habe mir mal was aus den Fingern gesorgt.
Was, ich habe mir so überlegt, was könnte denn heute Abend, was könnte dran kommen, ja?
Also, was, was, wo ich, wo ich drauf wetten könnte, dass das in irgendeiner Form kommt, ist das Erste.
YouTuber, beziehungsweise irgendein C-Promi, der auf der Bühne steht und was zu dem Game erzählt und dass er das schon immer gespielt hat.
Oder, dass er da schon immer ein Fan von ist und...
Absolut begeistert ist und sich jetzt so wahnsinnig freut, dass er mal mitarbeiten kann an irgendeinem...
An der Ehe, wisst ihr ja, ne?
Also, dass das kommt, das kommt garantiert.
Garantiert.
Irgendein YouTuber, C-Promi, wer in 100 Pro...
Sinnloses Mobile-Game, könnte ich auch fast wetten, dass da irgendwas kommt.
Muss.
Ähm...
Battle Royale?
Mich, mich würde es wundern, wenn das nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise kommt.
So.
Also, im Prinzip sind das ja alles Sachen, die bei EA...
Alles nicht sehr unwahrscheinlich ist, ne?
Vor allem das hier, Pay2Win als nicht Pay2Win getarnt.
Die haben ja aus Battlefront 2 und dem ganzen Zeug und Lootboxen, die haben ja schon ein bisschen draus gelernt.
Die machen jetzt Pay2Win, die machen jetzt Beziehungsweise...
Oder Lootboxen allerdings halt, ohne es Lootboxen zu nennen.
Denn mal gucken, was ihnen da einfällt bei der ganzen Sache.
Äh...
Was? Es fehlt Immersive Gameplay.
Naja, ich hab hier sowas reingeschrieben wie Ananandereien von Superlative.
Superlative.
The most amazing, best ever, of all time...
Hast du nicht gesehen.
So, Free2Play, kommt vielleicht auch irgendwas.
Äh...
Football...
Muss, das ist immer in EA.
Wo du den E3-Stream angucken kannst.
Twitch.
EA.
Ähm...
Dass irgendein Auto auf die Bühne kommt, wie letztes Jahr, kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen.
Indie-Devs, die nicht Indie sind, könnte ich auch fast wetten, dass da...
Irgendwie sowas kommt.
Wisst ihr, so nach dem Motto, wir...
Ähm...
Nehmen uns ein Studio und davon halt nicht alle, sondern nur vier Leute und sagen, das sind Indie-Devs.
Wisst ihr, das ist so, wie wenn man sagen würde, Hearthstone.
Hearthstone wurde von Indie-Devs gemacht.
Einfach nur, weil Blizzard nicht die komplette Manpower dran gesetzt hat, bloß irgendwie acht Leute oder so.
Das machen die Leute allgemein relativ gerne.
Und das hier, das werden wir auch viel haben bei EA.
Ähm...
Vor allem...
Vor allem im Sportteil werden wir ganz viel haben.
Ähm...
Aber das machen sie ja generell gerne, so nach dem Motto, wir lieben Indie-Devs und wir haben ja auch ganz viele tolle Förderprogramme.
Und dann guckt man mal nach, wozu die gehören.
Das sind überhaupt keine Indie-Devs.
So.
Äh...
Battlefield 5 wird irgendwas kommen und irgendwas von War Simulator und...
Authentisch und sonst was erzählen sie.
Wie lange das Ganze dauert, weiß ich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich...
Wahrscheinlich geht da...
Boah, es gibt ja schon In-Game-Footage.
Das kommt garantiert auch.
Aber wie gesagt, es geht noch nicht los.
Wir können jetzt einfach mal gucken, wie ist so die Lautstärke.
Passt das so?
Lautstärke vom Stream zu Lautstärke von mir.
Ist das...
Ist das okay?
Football, Resident Sleeper.
Auf welches Spiel freust du dich am meisten auf der EA Play?
Sims 5.
That's right.
This year, Madden and a few...
NFL Mobile becomes Madden NFL Overdrive.
I am here with Mark and Joe and they're gonna go...
Madden NFL Overdrive.
Ist das denn hier allein schon der Name?
Dann könnte ich...
Dann könnte ich jetzt hier allein schon hier mal ankreuzen, so.
Madden NFL Overdrive Mobile.
Ja, was...
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Das ist geil.
Es schreiben zwei Leute direkt nebeneinander.
Stream etwas leiser, würde ich sagen.
Stream ist ein bisschen leiser.
Ja, was?
Was?
Was denn jetzt?
Also, neue Star Wars Game.
Weiß man nicht.
Könnte gut sein.
Basketball wahrscheinlich.
Fußball mit Sicherheit.
Cringe mit...
Garantiert.
Customization.
Könnt ihr drauf wetten.
Irgendein merkwürdiger Need for Speed Trailer, wo sich die Leute fragen so nach dem...
Warum muss Need for Speed so komisch sein?
Dann wieder natürlich die üblichen Geschichten, dass man angeblich das live gespielte Real In-Game-Footage-Gameplay sieht.
Wo man sich immer streiten kann, ob das überhaupt...
Vor allem, ob das real ist.
Und ob das In-Game und live ist schon was ganz...
Ganz was anderes.
Das kommt wahrscheinlich auch.
Dass irgendwie ein Sportler irgendeinen Football oder einen Golfer oder einen UFC-Typ oder einen...
Keine Ahnung.
Irgendeinen, den wir wahrscheinlich nicht kennen, auf der Bühne stehen wird.
Und erzählt von seinem Leben so nach dem Motto, wie geil er das findet.
Er hat als kleines Kind schon immer davon geträumt, mal in FIFA dabei etwas...
Ja, bla halt.
Dann gibt es wahrscheinlich irgendwelche UFC-Golf-Geschichten.
Und dann schläfst du ein.
Also mit Sims war übrigens nicht ansgemein gerade, ne?
Natürlich freue ich mich am meisten auf Battlefield 5.
Mal gucken, was da gezeigt wird.
Eventuell gibt es ja wieder Sims mit irgendwelchen Tieren dabei.
Weil sie sonst nichts zu zeigen haben.
Exclusive für irgendwas wird es auch auf jeden Fall.
Exclusive ohne Ende.
So, das...
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Das...
Also die zwei Sachen gehören so irgendwie zusammen.
Weil ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass sie quasi ein bisschen Battlefront 2 loben.
So nach dem Motto.
Dank eurem grandiosen Feedback konnten wir unser gutes Spiel noch viel besser machen.
So wie ihr es euch schon immer gewünscht habt.
Und haben jetzt die beste Star Wars Experience aller Zeiten.
Na, ihr wisst ja sowas in der Richtung.
Kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Und die besten Fans haben wir natürlich auch.
Irgendwelche DLCs wird es geben.
Und schlechte Musik wird es auch jede Menge geben.
Und sei es nur das neue Battlefield-Theme, wenn es wieder so komische Dubstep-Mischmasch ist.
Den Buzzword-Counter.
Brauchen wir noch den Buzzword-Counter?
Wir haben schon so viele Counters.
Und so viel Zeug.
Vielleicht beleben sie Dead Space wieder.
Ich finde Dead Space kann ruhig Dead Game bleiben.
Das erste Dead Space war wirklich ein super Game.
Vor allem von der Atmosphäre.
Dead Space 2 war doof.
Und Dead Space 3 war angeblich gar nicht so doof.
Aber ich bin nie bis zu dem Teil gekommen, wo es anfängt nicht doof zu sein.
So, 20 Minuten noch.
Oh mein Gott, man kriegt Notifikationen, wenn einer gescored hat.
Madden Mobile.
So, ich habe jetzt ein bisschen lauter gemacht.
Sagt mir mal, ob das jetzt besser ist.
Du hast so voll wie auf der Gamescom.
Ja.
Streamlink.
Und er crabt das dann von Twitch.
Allerdings, wenn dir der Streamer gefällt, guckst trotzdem am besten über die App oder
über den Browser.
Da profitiert der Streamer mehr davon.
Wenn du sagst, ich scheiß da drauf, dann guckst du über VLC.
Ich mach das eigentlich nur, wenn ich irgendwas aufnehmen will
Über Streamlink
Ansonsten, du hast ja auch kein Chat
Deswegen, für mich gehört
Für mich gehört Chat
Was ist da los?
Zwölf
By the way
Der war doch nicht
Der war eben mit dem Alter
Der darf wahrscheinlich noch gar nicht auf die Bühne
Ohne Erlaubnis von Mutter und Vater
Ja, guck das mal an
Alter
Der ist zwölf oder so
Habt ihr den
Habt ihr den Rage Quit
Habt ihr den, Leute, habt ihr den FIFA Rage Quit gesehen?
Kennt ihr das
FIFA Rage Quit Video?
Dauert noch 18 Minuten bis los
Kennt ihr das FIFA Rage Quit Video?
Ups
Nein
Guck mal, ob ich das finde
Das ist
Das ist das nicht
Ja, das ist es
Hier, guck mal
Rage Quit
Das ist irgendein FIFA Turnier
Das ist irgendein FIFA Turnier, ne?
Und
Ich mach mal an
Warte mal
So
Und es gibt wohl in FIFA
So irgendwie eine
Wie ich das gelesen habe
So die absolute No-Skill-Mechanik
Dass du quasi, wenn du vorne liegst
Einfach das Game stallst ohne Ende
Du passt dir einfach nur noch den Ball hin und her
Und das Game kann damit nicht umgehen
Das heißt, der, der jetzt hier führt
Der fuckt den halt voll ab
Weil er quasi
Naja, ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Glitch ist, ja
Und das pisst den halt übelst an
Und gleich kommt der Rage Quit
Mitten im Turnier
Mitten im Turnier, ne?
Die Runde läuft noch
Mitten im Turnier
Rage Quit?
Verpisst euch
Habt keinen Bock mehr
So mit
Ey, in welchem Turnier siehst du sowas, ja?
Und vor allem, warum ist das Ding die Mechanik in dem Game?
The fuck?
Oh nein, besonders in dem Game
Und wo wir gerade dabei sind
Kennt ihr den...
Äh
Kennt ihr das StarCraft Turnier, wo der Typ mit dem Fuß spielt?
Ich meine, wir haben noch 15 Minuten Zeit
Wir können uns noch ein bisschen Zeug einkommen
Kennt ihr das StarCraft...
Das ist auch irgendein Turnier, ja?
Er spielt mit dem Fuß
Oh, ich kann das glauben, Mann
Ich...
Das ist ein...
Oh!
Oh mein Gott!
Das ist so geil!
Das ist verrückt!
Das ist...
Oh mein Gott!
Das ist ein wunderschöner...
Das ist einfach mal komplett Expanding Brain hier
Das ist Next Level
Absolut Next Level
Das geht...
In Wirklichkeit geht das noch viel länger, ne?
Das geht irgendwie 37 Minuten
Der spielt dann auch irgendwie...
Irgendwie umgedreht und irgendwie...
Ach, ganz...
Der macht die ganze Zeit so komisches Zeug und zieht den halt übelst ab
Kannst du Lull rotieren lassen?
Na klar, siehst du doch hier, guck
Lull 3D und jetzt kann ich sogar den da machen
Das ist Turmspringer Lull
Oh, der Sirius Maxx, nice, nice
Der Sirius Maxx hat die Bullshit...
Die Bullshit-Bingo-Karte
Ich poste das nochmal
Die Bullshit-Bingo...
Haben wir eigentlich irgendwelche Mods?
Ja, der Sbarro war doch eben da, ne?
Haben wir irgendwelche Mods?
Könntest du das hier vom Sirius Maxx mal als Ausrufezeichen Bingo-Link oder irgendwie sowas einrichten?
So, wir dürfen den Anfang nicht verpassen
Grills
Wir dürfen den Anfang nicht verpassen
Da haben wir noch 13 Minuten haben wir noch Zeit
Sbarro ist futtern
Keine Mods
Oh, ich ahne Schlimmes
Da muss ich jetzt, glaube ich, irgendeinen...
Wer macht denn hier einen guten Eindruck?
Der Sirius Maxx, den habe ich schon öfters gesehen
Der macht einen guten Eindruck
Der wird jetzt gemoddet
Den habe ich schon öfters gesehen hier
Und wenn du Blödsinn machst, wirst du entmoddet
Weil ohne Mod geht's hier nicht
So, ähm...
Aber das war...
Das ist der Geil, oder?
Das ist wirklich Next Level Shitter-Typ, der Starcraft im Fuß spielt
Magst du mal die Low Latency-Option aktivieren?
Ja, das ist der Geil, oder?
Wo aktiviert man dann die Low Latency-Option?
Ha! Jetzt kommen sie hier mit Message Delete
Das hast du aber geschickt gemacht
Du hast es schon auf Deutsch geschrieben
Nachricht gelöscht
Ja, ja, ist klar
So einfach könnt ihr mich nicht debaten
Ich bin Master, was Twitch-Chat angeht
Ich habe eine eigene Textdatei mit Twitch-Chat, Copypasta und Memes
Die ist mittlerweile...
Ich gucke mal kurz rein, ich zeige die euch nicht
Weil das ist ja meine, quasi meine Geheimwaffe
Die ist, ähm...
183 Zeilen
183 Zeilen lang
Meine Twitch-Chat-Copypasta-Meme-Datei
Das heißt, Twitch-Chat
Da...
Da können wir mich nicht verarschen mit
So, 10 Minuten noch
Sims
Mir fällt mir dazu nicht ein
Dashboard-Settings-Channel
Ne, ich kann, wenn ich jetzt Low Latency anmache
Dann startet sich das Team wahrscheinlich neu, ne?
Ich gucke mal, wie viel Latency ich habe
Ich gucke mal in meiner Vorschau
So
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs
Acht, neun, zehn
Zehn Sekunden, damit kann man doch leben, oder?
9,22
Das ist zu wenig
Ja, Stream-Snipe, Achtung
Nicht, dass ich gesniped werde
99,9 Sekunden
Ich glaube, mit dem Delay können wir leben
Ich will jetzt nix
Ich will jetzt nix an den Settings rumspielen
Und dann kackt der Stream ab
Ich meine, bei so einer...
Also, ich glaube, mit dem Delay können wir leben
Ich glaube, mit dem Delay können wir leben
Wenn man, wenn das jetzt irgendwie Gameplay wäre
Oder irgendwie so, so quasi
Chat plays Overwatch
Oder irgendwie sowas, ja
Dann wäre die Latenz natürlich wichtig
Aber wenn wir uns eine Pressekonferenz angucken
Hey, ob die jetzt 9,9 Sekunden später ist
Oder nicht, ist egal
Wieso spielen die im Stehen?
Wahrscheinlich können die sich keine Stühle leisten
Und vielleicht ist es nicht hip genug
Zu sitzen
Weißt du, kennt man die?
Boah
Ich mach den Sound mal wieder aus
Ich ahne Schlimmes schon
Das wird, das wird grausam gleich
So, wir müssen
Genau
Unser Bullshit-Bingo ist offen
Wir haben schon, sag, wunderbar
Alles vorbereitet
Wir können direkt loslegen
Ähm, falls ich irgendwas vergesse, Leute, ne?
Spamt mich im Chat voll
Dass ich, dass ich dran denke, hier
Bullshit-Bingo auszufüllen
Also, EA schlachtet ja alles aus
Aber Sims ist da schon wirklich ganz gut
Ganz oben mit dabei
Was ist mit Anthem?
Ja, ich geh mal davon aus, da kommt auch was
EA-Leute interviewen EA-Leute
Wie toll EA-Produkte sind
Haha
Ah
Äh, Patrick, was?
Was?
Wat?
Ich versteh's nicht
Ich bin mal gespannt
Ob sie was zu, ähm
Battlefield eSport erzählen
Ich hab das absichtlich mal hier rausgelassen
Äh
Weil es EA eSport-technisch noch nicht so richtig auf die Reihe gekriegt haben, was Battlefield sowas anbelangt.
Sie erzählen das zwar öfters mal.
Aber sie machen ja nichts, wirklich.
Weil Incursions...
Ist Incursions?
Battlefield eSport, was ist das ja?
Das ist...
Sie haben irgendwie ja vor einer Weile erzählt, sie haben eine eSport-Division oder sowas gegründet.
Davon habe ich noch nichts mitgekriegt.
Was die tolles macht, die eSport-Division.
Hallo, Troy-Deezer.
Troy-Deezer.
Also das können wir safe abhaken heute.
Das können wir safe abhaken.
Kann man die Stream-Quali ändern?
Ja, sollte eigentlich gehen.
Das hat er manchmal, dass es bei mir nicht einzustellen geht.
Manchmal geht das dann nach einer Zeit und manchmal geht es auch nicht.
Lustigerweise hatte ich gestern mit exakt, den wirklich exakt,
den kleinen...
In den gleichen Settings hatte ich Optionen.
Das liegt aber wahrscheinlich daran, also gar nicht an mir, sondern einfach wie viele Leute gerade streamen
und wen halt Twitch für wichtig hält, dass man halt Rechenleistung bei ihnen kriegt.
Und ich bin anscheinend nicht wichtig genug und dann...
Das verstehe ich ja auch.
Ich meine, ich bin weder Partner, ich bring Twitch oder noch Affiliate, noch Partner oder sonst was.
Ich bringe Twitch nichts an Geld.
Gar nichts.
Ich koste ja nur was.
Deswegen sind sie wahrscheinlich der Meinung, alle anderen sind wichtiger, Optionen zu kriegen.
Aber ist okay, verstehe ich.
Oh, gleich geht's los.
So, ungefähr so die Lautstärke, denke ich, weil wird's auch im Stream sein.
Geht doch, oder?
Der Typ versteht man doch gut.
Oder soll ich noch einen Ticken lauter machen?
Ich kann ja immer noch lauter machen.
Sollte es nicht passen.
Einen Tick lauter.
Wir warten, bis es losgeht, dann mache ich lauter.
Sobald es losgeht.
Die Musik ist nice.
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich schaue.
Ob er Max oder Pete Sweet guckt.
Macht doch einfach beide auf.
Das Schöne ist ja, das ist überhaupt kein Problem mit der Bandbreite, die man heutzutage so hat.
Meistens.
Die Leute sitzen da unten, hängen raus.
Die Leute, die das Show machen.
Ich meine, Battlefield 5 hat schon einen, ich weiß gar nicht, was er ist, irgendeinen Comedian-Typ gehostet.
Wie heißt, wie hieß der denn?
Wie ist der Typ, der Battlefield 5 gehostet hat, das Reveal?
Mein Mann Dylan hier.
Dylan, wie geht's?
Wie geht's, Bruder?
Alles klar.
Erzähl mir über das Paladin.
Für was ist genau das Meme-Tool, was du programmiert hast?
Das hat man doch gesehen hier.
Ja, für sowas.
Da ich so Dinge hier einblenden kann, quasi als Overlay.
Ups, äh, ich hab's kaputt gemacht.
Trevor Noah, genau.
Dass ich sowas einblenden kann.
Dafür ist das Meme-Tool.
Leck.
Der Sibaro ist back.
WB.
Kleine Info an meine Mods, die jetzt da sind.
Ich hab den Serious Max gemoddet.
Wir hatten keine Mods, wir haben Mods gebraucht.
Und er hat in den letzten Streams schon immer einen guten Eindruck gemacht.
Oh, guck mal, der Jowson ist da.
Meme-Tool.
Und mehr Mods können nix schaden.
Ich hatte ja bisher, glaube ich, nur drei oder so.
Ha- Was, Hanzo?
I was rapping.
We're still going.
We're not rapping.
We're still-
I was lying to you.
Welcome to the family fun zone, my friend.
This is where you-
You can get all your real racing action on.
Simple Geometry.
Hat er gerade was von Hanzo erzählt?
Say, perhaps you'd like to play a game in a race chair with a steering wheel.
Rio-
Rio-va-
Ta-
Ta-ki-wo-
Ta-ki-wo-crow.
Oder so ähnlich.
I'm just like, I'm just like, no pressure.
Hanzo.
Put the cameras on.
There's a ball pit over here.
There's food over here.
We're going inside.
Let's head inside and check out the show.
Ja.
Lass mal inside headen.
Twelve, by the way.
Oh mein Gott!
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wer das ist.
Right behind these doors there is a fan fest outside.
Zu leise?
Ist okay?
Oder soll ich lauter machen?
It's a full three day gaming festival where thousands of gamers can come and play games for free.
Now, inside the theater here there are hundreds of community members from all over the world
who are going to be streaming and getting their first impressions of the games that we're going to be showing off here today.
But, before we can get to that, we've got some reveals, of course,
we're going to kick things off with a look at Battlefield 5 Multiplayer.
Now, you know, the game should start with the game itself, right?
Trevor Noah hat euch den ersten Blick gegeben. Ja, wir können es aufklatschen.
Letztes Monat, aber wir haben noch ein paar neue Sachen, die wir euch heute zeigen.
Dann gehen wir weiter mit FIFA 19. Und, Junge, haben sie ein paar große Neuigkeiten, ihr Jungs.
Welche Weltcup-Fans? Seid ihr gespannt?
Ja, das wird großartig.
Dann haben wir zwei neue Indie-Games, die wir teilen.
Und dann komme ich zurück, bis zum Ende des Shows, mit einigen meiner Lieblings-Developern,
um euch einen schönen, niedlichen Blick auf Anthem zu geben.
Da bin ich gespannt.
Wir können eigentlich schon mit Cringe anfangen, abzuhaken, oder?
Merkt euch mal, was wir anhaken müssen.
Customisation können wir auch schon abhaken.
Cringe können wir abhaken.
The deepest and most immersive battlefield, yes.
It certainly is.
You will be able to dive and smash through windows to surprise your enemies.
Where previously defenses were stationary,
you will now be able to move these weapons around on the battlefield and gain advantages.
And our renowned destruction system is back and more impactful than ever.
Das sieht...
You can't really hide from those pesky tanks.
And more as they come chasing it for you, as they rip through those buildings.
And you will now be able to customize your soldiers, your vehicles and your weapons, not
only for the gameplay, but for the looks, as part of our portrayal of the Second World
War.
And that's just the tip of the iceberg.
Et das sieht schon geil aus.
You're going to see a lot more of our new gameplay systems here at EA Play from our
community.
So, let's talk about our single player in War Stories.
Yes, let's do that.
So, we want to tell you about those untold stories that got us excited to start with on
this game.
It's about what you will see is really those moments of human heroism.
It is about witnessing the war...
Was sagt mir das Bild jetzt?
... the men and the women who shaped the world forever.
Real and relatable people facing the brutality of war.
We started off by a exclusive...
Exclusive look at the Nordlys War Story.
Great.
... at the Xbox briefing tomorrow.
Thanks, that's something not to miss tomorrow.
So, our launching in October is just the beginning.
You will all go on an expanding journey through the Second World War.
No loot boxes.
No premium pads.
Boxes.
Aber definitiv irgendwas, Leute.
Ihr habt irgendwas.
Every day, we'll bring something new.
We'll bring something new.
And as part of that journey, after launch, you'll get something I know a lot of you have
been asking for.
It's Royale.
Ich wusste es.
Abhaken.
It's Royale reimagined for Battlefield.
So, we bring those pillars of Battlefield, like destruction, teamplay, vehicles, into
this new experience.
Gleich abhaken.
So...
Und das ist euer erster Blick auf Ground Operations.
Und dieses Mal sogar mit Musik.
Das gefällt mir auch schon viel besser als der erste Trailer.
Das ist nice.
Das macht doch schon...
Leute, sagt doch mal.
Das macht doch einen viel besseren Eindruck als der erste Trailer.
Game Engine Footage.
Oh nein, das ist FIFA.
Okay, Leute.
Wir können eigentlich abschalten, oder?
Exclusive können wir auch abhaken.
Wir haben ja schon das halbe...
Okay.
Ihr Leute...
Ihr wollt FIFA gucken, oder?
Sonst könnte ich mal meinen...
meinen Bullshit-Bingo-Zettel abhaken,
während FIFA läuft.
Aber das Ebaro trackt das Ganze schon.
Das machen wir danach dann.
Based God.
Was geht jetzt?
Warum ist das gerade so episch?
Mit epischer Musik und...
Kirchen-Klubs teilweise.
Und Signals des Spiels wie Gerrard und Kroy
haben ihre Vorgehensweise genutzt.
Die auf Aside-League großartig gut zusammengezogen ist.
Ein specially thank you
der legendäre Hans Zimmer
und L.A.'s eigener Vin admitted
für der honestly знаем wir doch das ist ein Trainer
er
Ja, das hört sich auch nach Hans Zimmer an.
Die Musik...
für wie die Champions League in FIFA 19
in lebend ist...
Und Lina wird euch noch viel darüber hören.
Wie Aaron gesagt hast,
der UEFA Champions League ist,
Wer ist das jetzt genau?
Sind das...
Wer ist das denn, der das...
Oh, thrilled sind wir. Thrilled.
Ah, das ist der FIFA-Direktor.
Na, was haben sie denn diesmal wieder re-invented, re-imagined oder all-new-best-of-all-time gemacht?
Ist da jetzt nicht schon zum gefühlten achten Mal Ronaldo drauf?
Ich bin extrem aufgeregt, dass alle es spielen, wenn wir es am 28. September starten.
Und das ist unsere FIFA-19-News, die von der UEFA Champions League bezeichnet wurde.
Aber ich wollte nur einen Moment nehmen, um zu pausieren und zu reflektieren.
Standen neben diesem Trophäe ist ein bisschen surreal.
Weißt du, als ich geboren wurde, gab es zwei eikonische Trophäe, die jeder junge Spieler wünschte, dass er gewinne.
Und für deinen Klub ist es dieser hier.
Die Beobachtung der Champions-League-Glorie.
Aber für dein Land ist es dieses Trophäe.
Der Weltcup.
Und mit dem Tournament, das in nur fünf Tagen beginnt, sind wir bereit, den Weltcup in FIFA 18 zu gewinnen.
Wie du dir vorstellen kannst, können alle von uns auf der FIFA-Team nicht warten, bis der Weltcup beginnt.
Und wir wollen mit den FIFA-18-Spielern feiern, weshalb wir gerade das Spiel gemacht haben,
mit einer freien Weltcup-Erfahrung auf Playstation 4, Xbox One, PS,
PC und Nintendo Switch.
Aber du kannst den Weltcup-Wertzug nicht nehmen.
Oder du kannst dich von einer großen Nation, die dieses Jahr nicht qualifiziert hat, verlassen.
Oder du kannst dir einen verrückten Traum machen, eine Realität für dein Heimatland wie mein, Iceland.
Wer hätte gedacht, dass eine Nation von nur 350.000 Menschen jemals qualifiziert wäre?
Und du kannst deine Erwartungen gewinnen.
EASY CLAP! EASY CLAP! EASY CLAP!
Und auf PC durch Origin Access.
Ja, du kannst...
Free? Origin Access kostet Geld?
...für gratis.
Das ist nicht gratis!
Also, um das Trial auszulösen, haben wir einige der weltweit größten Kreatoren.
Wir werden live am Ende des Shows spielen, die ihre Nationen im Mini-Weltcup-Tournament repräsentieren.
Und dieses Sommer bringen wir so viel mehr für die FIFA-Fans.
Viel mehr FIFA-18-Initiativ, das sich um die Weltcup konzentriert.
Und wir bringen euch...
alle Details über die FIFA-19.
Aber in der Zwischenzeit...
lasst uns alle die Weltcup genießen.
Danke und...
AUFRAVISTAN!
Okay, schlechte Musik können wir schon mal abhaken.
Guck mal, wie schlecht die Spieler aussehen, ey.
Also, die Models.
Ich...
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab irgendwie das Gefühl, sie kriegen es im Battlefield ja auch übelst geil hin, ne?
So...
Aber die Spielermodels in FIFA sehen irgendwie immer kacke aus.
Oh nee.
Ich dachte, es ist fertig.
20 Millionen Menschen aus 60 Ländern spielen dieses Jahr in konkurrenzierten Ligen.
Nun, die FIFA-Team bleibt nicht aufhören, die Champions League, die Weltcup und so viele andere Fehlzeiten zu FIFA zu bringen.
Wir warten nicht auf euch, das alles zu erleben.
Wir haben heute so viel zu tun, aber ich möchte euch willkommen an die EA Play zu geben.
Das ist die dritte EA Play und unsere zweite in Hollywood und wir könnten uns nicht mehr freuen, euch mit zu haben,
um alle Spiele zu teilen, die wir euch zeigen müssen.
Wir müssen mal gucken, ob wir den Mashed oder Lost im Publikum sehen.
Das ist mir zu hoch.
Das macht man hier nicht mit, was er erzählt gerade.
Wahrscheinlich erkenne ich es einfach nur nicht.
Was ich soll den Stream noch lauter machen?
Soll ich?
Ja, nein, nein, ja, ja.
Okay, dann mache ich ein Stückchen.
Es gibt zwei Dinge, die ihr wissen müsst.
Origin Access Premier bringt euch alle unsere neuen PC-Spiele,
starten mit Madden NFL,
zurück auf dem PC für das erste Mal in über einer Dekade,
dann FIFA 19, Battlefield 5 und natürlich Anthem.
Und es werden viele mehr Titel in den nächsten Jahren.
Zweitens bekommt ihr Zugang zu The Vault,
unsere Bibliothek von über 100 Spielen von EA und anderen Publishern.
Und drittens wird es später im Sommer eröffnet.
Das ist etwas später im Jahr, aber wenn ihr die Spiele einfach kaufen möchtet und die Vorteile und Freude der Abonnenten erfahren möchtet,
dann kommt rein und spielt einen kostenlosen Trial von Origin Access, unsere Basisubskription, dieses Wochenende.
Danke und habt einen schönen Tag.
Also wenn man viele Spiele von denen haben will, macht das vielleicht Sinn, keine Ahnung, mal gucken, was es kostet.
Aber wenn man sich ab und zu mal ein EA-Spiel kauft, macht das wahrscheinlich überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Zumal die alten Games, die hat man ja, wenn man sie spielen will, meistens schon.
Also, ja, mal gucken, mal gucken, was da genau drin ist und was es dann kostet am Ende.
Es wäre interessant zu wissen, wie es mit DLCs und Season Passes und solchen Geschichten bei Origin Access Premiere aussieht.
Also sprich, mal genommen, ich krieg Battlefield über Premiere.
Was sind dann die DLCs drin?
Mr. Vince Zampella hier in the audience from Respawn.
Hey, guys.
What's going on, Vince? How are you feeling today?
I'm feeling great. I love this stuff. I love seeing new games.
I mean, someone's super excited about that man on PC, right? Yeah!
So, I'd like to say that Vince was tweeting yesterday and there has been a bunch of speculation.
So, you want to just get right to it?
Sure. I mean, we're not ready to show all of our stuff yet.
We're working on a bunch of stuff. It's amazing. The teams are kicking ass.
But we wanted to bring a little tidbit.
So, we've been working with Lucas on getting the name and kind of the setting for what our Star Wars game is going to be.
And we're going to talk about it right now.
Ah, Star Wars.
Oh, you guys got any guesses? I bet you the Internet is going wild right now.
Oh, ich weiß gar nicht, was ich gerade vorgestellt habe.
So, the Star Wars name is Jedi Fallen Order.
Woo! So, Star Wars Jedi Fallen Order.
So, it kind of gives you some idea that you'll be playing a Jedi.
So, does that mean I get to like hold a lightsaber?
Yes.
So, Vince.
Das ist der Typ, der früher bei Activision war und jetzt in der zweiten Folge du uns mitmachst.
Wenn ich nicht ganz falsch liege.
But when the Jedi's are being hunted, so it's going to be spectacular.
So, for all the hardcore nerds out there who want to know like where in the timeline,
like between which Jedi's are being hunted, so it's going to be spectacular.
Between which episodes is it?
Between three and four.
Okay. Alright, between three and four. That sounds like a nice time.
You got any other tidbits?
It's not a nice...
It's a dark time.
Bad time. Does that mean it's going to just be all dark and serious?
It's amazing.
Alright, so I think people are now anxiously want to know like when can we play the game?
It will be holiday of next...
Next year, 2019, not this year.
Sorry to dash any hopes.
But now that we know, we can set expectations, we're all going to be amped up.
And hopefully we'll hear more from you maybe next year.
Oh yeah.
Well Vince, it was great to see you. Thanks for stopping by the show today.
We do have a little bit more news on Star Wars, so I'm going to toss it over to Dennis.
Das hat's jetzt voll gebracht, dass der da war, oder?
Hey Dennis.
Gut, dass du das schon gemerkt hast.
And make sure that we were delivering the game that our players really wanted.
Und der hat irgendwas genommen, oder?
So we decided to completely overhaul our progression system and add a bunch of new character cosmetics for players to collect instead.
So from there, we added a new hunt mode inspired by the original Battlefront games that I loved personally, starting with the Ewoks on Endor.
And...
Hitting all sorts of cacophones.
Thank you.
It turned out to be by far the most popular update of the game and the team loved building Ewok Hunt.
So as you might know, we're currently in our Han Solo season with content from the movie coming next week.
Exposed.
It's headlined by the new planet Kessel, a really dangerous place, and it features the return of one of our favorite modes, extraction.
So looking forward a little bit.
This summer we will be introducing a new squad system to the game.
Battlefront 2 Schadensbegrenzung. Können wir ausfüllen im Bullshit Bingo.
We're also adding a new starfighter mode focused around dogfighting with your hero ships.
And looking ahead a little bit more, we will also be delivering a new logistic multiplayer sandbox experience focused around capturing command posts.
And attacking and taking out capital ships.
But that's not all.
We know that you have been asking for new heroes, villains and planets from a certain era that features a very iconic Star Wars conflict.
So I'm excited to confirm that Battlefront 2 this year will be going deep into the Clone Wars.
It's only fitting that we begin on the planet Geonosis featuring multiple levels.
Including the largest level we have ever built for Battlefront.
So let's talk about the heroes and villains.
First, let me introduce the most powerful droid army in the galaxy, General Grievous.
And yes, he will be going up against my own personal favorite, Jedi Master Obi-Wan Kenobi.
Finally making his debut in Battlefront after all these years.
So, but we're...
We're not done.
That's not it.
They will not come alone.
Joining them is the Dark Lord and leader of the Separatist Alliance, Count Dooku.
As well as...
That's Christopher Lee.
That's the only one I know.
Obi-Wan's unruly padawan, Anakin Skywalker.
The team at home is extremely excited to be building all of these cool things.
EA and DICE are committed to Battlefront.
We had a rough start.
But I really think that this battle...
This game has a bright future.
Thank you very much for playing the game.
Providing us with...
Battlefront 2 hat bestimmt die brightest future von allen Games.
Ist klar.
...the greatest game that we can possibly build.
There would be no Battlefront without you.
Ist klar.
So thank you.
We look forward to seeing you with you.
And enjoy the rest of E3.
Thanks.
Ah, das ist...
Was?
Unravel 2 oder sowas wahrscheinlich, ja?
Hi.
It's really good to see you.
Ah, das ist...
Unravel 2 oder sowas wahrscheinlich, ja?
Hi.
It's really good to see you.
In Unravel we used yarn to symbolize love and the bonds between people.
In our new game we tear that bond up right at the start.
You lose everything, including your spark.
But, when things are at their darkest, you find hope.
And you form a new bond.
Ich habe das erste noch nicht gespielt, aber wollte ich schon die ganze Zeit mal.
Also gute Koop-Spiele kann es nie genug geben.
Ob so was taugt?
Mal gucken.
Ja, Sembaro, ich hab's gesehen.
Haha.
Ach.
Fuck.
Ja.
Ja, genau.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du es wirklich kannst.
Aber doch.
Es geht so viel.
Also das Ergebnis, das ich jetzt ausprobieren will...
Es ist der erste Mal, dass wir noch ein Spiel ausprobieren wollen, das wir früherμαßen
nicht von der Idee der Pro-Uhr zusammen gemacht haben.
Und wir denken, dass es ein wertvoller Erfolgsvorsprung ist.
Ich will dir das jetzt zeigen, ich habe mir auch Hilfe gebracht.
Willkommen Michael auf der Bühne.
Ich bin der Produzent von Coldwood.
Und wir werden dir ein bisschen zeigen, worüber wir reden, wie du das Spiel in der Koop
spielen kannst.
Im Grunde.
So, das war noch nicht vorbereitet.
Wack.
Da sind wir.
So, da sind wir.
Wenn du es selbst spielst, kannst du die anderen Charaktere
und führst sie durch die mehr schnellen Segmente des Spiels.
Und wir haben versucht, ein bisschen mehr davon einzuführen,
weil wir wussten, dass es ein Koop-Spiel ist,
und wir wollten mehr Spannung und Gefahr und Wilde Momente haben.
Plätze, die lustig und aufregend waren.
Und dann, wenn du zu den mehr puzzeligen Bereichen kommst,
wenn du Probleme löst, kannst du sie in zwei Teile trennen
und zwischen den beiden Charakteren wiederholen.
Denn das ist die Art und Weise, wie wir die Probleme und Puzzle des Spiels gestaltet haben.
Du arbeitest immer zusammen und helfst einander aus
und verwendest diese Verbindung zwischen dir,
um irgendwelche Obstacke zu überwinden, die du erlebst.
Also, ich glaube, ich komme jetzt rein.
Ja, komm, Yoni.
Also, ähm...
Ich werde in die Runde kommen.
Okay.
Du wirst die dunkle haben.
Ich werde die blaue haben.
Ich mache so Spiele.
Ich mache generell Spiele, die dir nicht so diese
AAA Blockbuster Zeug in die Fresse hauen.
Die gefallen mir in der Regel viel besser, als die Spiele, die du machst.
Der Vogel ist zurück.
Warte ein bisschen.
Ich spiele es jetzt in Sicherheit.
Oop.
Ich spiele den Ball.
Okay.
Und dann bekomme ich dich.
Und wenn du den Ball spielst?
Ja, bitte.
Okay, du fängst an.
Aber letztendlich geht es ja bloß darum, das Koop-Feature zu zeigen, also die werden sich schon was einfallen lassen.
Hoffe ich für sie.
Moment, wie kommt der Vogel da wieder hin?
Dein Turn.
Wie kommt der Vogel da hin?
Hier, lass ihn auf der linken Seite bleiben.
Jetzt gehe ich.
Da ist er.
Jetzt können wir wieder atmen.
Ja, endlich.
Oder können wir?
Das war ein kurzer Blick auf Unravel 2.
Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen.
Und bevor ich losgehe, möchte ich ein bisschen Liebe an das Team zurückgeben, weil...
Das ist echtes Gameplay, aber nicht live.
... es war ein total fantastischer Team-Effort auf so vielen Ebenen und jeder hat so hart gearbeitet.
Also, es gibt ein paar von uns von Coldwood hier und vielen Dank an sie und vielen Dank an alle, die zurückgekommen sind.
Und danke, ich liebe euch.
Der hat doch einen sympathischen Eindruck gemacht, oder?
Hab ich noch nie gesehen vorher, aber...
Der kann gerne öfters Sachen präsentieren.
Danke, Martin und dem brillanten Team von Coldwood.
Das Spiel war wirklich stark.
Diese Jungs haben einen tollen Job gemacht.
Und es ist klar, dass sie viel Leid haben.
Und ich kann persönlich nicht warten, Unravel 2 mit meinen Kindern zu spielen.
Aber was noch mehr großartig ist, ist, dass wir Unravel 2 heute für alle erhältlich machen werden.
Ja, das hast du richtig gehört.
Du wirst die beiden Jarnen auf ihre nächste große Erwartung nehmen, die heute beginnt.
Das Spiel ist fertig, es ist aus.
Das sah aber nicht...
Das ist FINISHED?
Also danke, Martin, und danke dem Team von Coldwood.
Okay, dann nehme ich alles wieder zurück, was ich gesagt habe.
Von wegen, es ist ja nur eine Demo und das ist bestimmt alles ganz toll.
Und ähm...
Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher.
Hab ich nicht gespielt.
Das war dieses Gefängnis-Ausbrech-Game.
Und jetzt ist es so weit vorbei.
Ist es überhaupt schon raus?
Ist es schon raus?
Anscheinend.
Okay, anscheinend ist es raus.
Es wollte ich spielen.
Das Game war gut, ja, das Spiel...
Könnten wir im Stream spielen.
Es war in Berlin, es heißt Joe My Games.
Als ich dieses Team kennengelernt habe und das Spiel gesehen habe, war ich sofort zu der Person, die diese Geschichte war.
Es ist eine, die eine sehr mächtige und wichtige Botschaft trägt.
Und es ist wie alles andere, was wir je gemacht haben.
Also, bitte willkommen, Conny Gepper, von Joe My Games, um dir mehr über die See der Leidenschaft zu erzählen.
Danke, Patrick.
Oh...
Ich erinnere mich immer noch daran, wie enthusiastisch Patrick war.
Und danach war unser ganzes Team, auch ich, super aufgeregt.
Es fühlt sich gerade ein bisschen so an.
Das würde bei mir genauso anhören, wenn ich auf der Bühne stehe.
Ich hätte wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen...
Ja, das kann ich verstehen.
Ich weiß ja nicht, wie groß das Studio ist oder was die so machen, keine Ahnung.
Wenn du da zum ersten Mal da stehst, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das schon ziemlich aufregend ist.
Ein Studio?
Ich würde es genauso sagen.
Übrigens, wir können abhaken.
Wenn Menschen zu leise sind, werden sie in Monster-Geschichten gewechselt.
Das ist am Grunde alles, was man hier sehen, hören und hoffentlich auch fühlen kann, während man SOS spielt.
Was das unterliegende Konzept so wichtig und so unik ist, ist, dass fast jeder Mensch zumindest irgendwie zu allen erinnern kann,
das Gefühl, sich leise zu fühlen.
In meinem Fall habe ich angefangen, die Geschichte zu schreiben, als ich das Leidigste in meinem Leben gefühlt habe.
Ich denke, als Künstler präzisierst du deine emotionale Welt, indem du sie auslässt und sie in dein Kunstwerk nimmst.
Ich bin immer noch überrascht, wie die Konzepte einfach aus mir flöten,
direkt in die Hand und auf das Papier.
Ich denke, das ist auch das, wieso so viele Menschen so instinktiv mit sich verbinden können,
weil es nicht eine Geschichte ist, obwohl es in einem fantastischen Umfeld stattfindet.
In SOS versuchen wir zu zeigen, wie Menschen verschiedene Arten von Leidigkeit erleben,
aber auch, wie Außenseiter, Freunde und Familien diejenigen sehen, die an Schwierigkeiten kämpfen.
Wir erreichen all das in lustigen Weichen, sodass Spieler...
Flayt man nicht über der hier Englisch rum, das kann von euch wahrscheinlich auch keiner wirklich besser.
... so.
Aber ein Spieler, der etwas tiefer schauen möchte, kann eine ganze emotionale Welt hinter all dem zeigen.
Sea of Solitude handelt von einer jungen Frau namens Kay,
die von einer so starken Leidenschaft leidet, dass ihr inneres Gefühl,
die Dunkelheit, die Angst, die Unerwartung...
Stellt euch erstmal auf so eine Bühne und erzählt, was nicht in eurer Muttersprache...
... und sie wird ein Monster.
Zuerst etwas über das, was ihr von ihr passiert, was ihr eben nicht tun solltet...
aber auch...
wie man sie in die Menschheit zurückwerfen kann.
Wichtig ist, dass die Zielsatz ermöglicht, alle diese Emotionen in Begegnung zu machen.
Einige werden größer, einige werden etwas kleiner, aber...
zu entdecken, auch deine zerstörte Partikulierung oder deine Selbstdauer
in der gleiche Weise, wie du deine Freude und seine Hoche benötigst.
This is what being human is all about.
And that's what our game is all about.
Thank you.
Ich hab doch keine Ahnung, um was es geht, aber...
Dazu kann ich bloß sagen, we are all sitting in one boat.
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, was mir das Game eigentlich sagen soll.
Ich hab...
Also, ich sitz grad ungefähr so da.
Also, mehr fällt mir dazu. Ich hab keinen Schimmer.
Okay, es ist...
Early 2019, das heißt, es ist noch ein Dreivierteljahr hin.
Aber...
Ich dachte, Neo ist the one.
Basketball abhaken im Bingo.
Just remember, though.
Jawoll! Schuh-Customization! Yeah!
And this is my squad.
Jetzt fehlt eigentlich bloß noch Basketball-Royal oder sowas.
My name's Shea Kivlin, aka Young Kiv. I'm from Seattle, Washington.
It's a big night for Young Kiv. He's been stuck at the quarterfinals.
And here he is now in his first championship game, looking to accomplish a goal.
Third and four throws it low. T.Y. drops it!
That was a phenomenal read!
And Drini's got the lead! 40-19!
I hate losing way more than I love winning.
Oh, we have an incredible matchup. It's a rematch.
Benavido...
It's gonna be your champion!
Can't play you again?
You wanna get smacked again on TV?
Hahaha, ha, ha, ha!
Every face knows!
Oh!
He's finally done it!
We go, we go, we go!
Der Jojo Smith Schuster!
Aha!
Okay, ihr könnt abhaken. Random C-Promi auf der Bühne.
How you doing? I've been good. You still recovering from that butt-whooping?
Wow, already starting. Okay.
Hi everybody, I'm Jojo Smith Schuster from the Pittsburgh Sliders.
As you guys can see, King of Touchdown Celebration.
Wobei, wahrscheinlich ist der Typ in den USA übelst bekannt, ne?
Aber ich kenne ihn nicht.
This is Young Kiv, Madding 18, Madding Champion.
Give it up for Young Kiv, y'all. Give it up.
Easy clap.
Young Kiv.
How has it been? You know, your success and your path, you know, to where you're at today?
Young Kiv. Ist er Kratos oder was?
Boy, boy, BOY!
When I was in high school, I was playing baseball, I hurt my arm.
So then I picked up Madding and at first I was really bad.
I was getting blown out online, but I kept at it.
I put more and more time into it.
Eventually I made my first tournament, but I had a big decision.
But I had a big decision.
Wow, okay.
So the key to be the number one player in Madding is to hurt your arm in baseball.
That's number one.
Number two.
You said you had the decision to go to your graduation or go to the tournament.
So like, what did you do?
I chased that money.
I still got my diploma, but I chased that money.
There you go.
We're out here chasing money.
That's awesome.
Okay.
Now the...
Die Zuschauer sitzen gerade ungefähr alle so da, glaube ich.
Was?
Wollt ihr?
Es war schwer.
Ich hatte viele schreckliche Verletzungen.
Ich war so nah, so viele Male.
Ich habe die Finale auf der TV gemacht.
Ich habe mich getrunken.
Aber all diese Verletzungen haben mir eine Menge mentaler Schwierigkeiten gegeben.
Und deshalb habe ich diesen Belt bekommen.
Das ist großartig.
Dieser Belt ist so großartig.
Es gibt viele...
Wow, unglaublich, großartig.
... auf diesem Belt für dich.
Well, heute EA Play.
Du weißt, der erste Blick auf den Madding 19 Trailer.
Super gespannt.
Es wird so lustig sein.
Es ist aufgelöst.
Ich wünsche mir ehrlich gesagt, dass ich hier stehen und euch für immer sprechen kann.
Aber ich werde euch nicht verletzen.
Ich werde euch nicht verletzen.
Ich werde euch rausen.
Ich versuche diesen Belt zu holen.
Wissen ihr was.
Rund zwei.
Also, wir sind raus.
Viel Spaß.
Aber es ist gut.
Du hast dein ganzes Leben gearbeitet, um an Momente wie diesen zu kommen.
An dem Top der Bergabend.
Du bist durch Schmerzen kämpft.
Da hätte ich mir lieber noch eine halbe Stunde was von SOS erzählen lassen.
Oh, Frostbite, oh!
Huge Play, genau, huge, huge!
Slow-Motion-Door-Breeching.
Also mir fehlt ehrlich gesagt noch, ich hoffe, die zeigen nochmal, guck mal, also mir fehlt Schweißtropfen-Physik.
Die bewegen sich nicht.
Das wäre eigentlich so der Next Step.
Schweißtropfen-Physik.
Man, Fischphysik gibt's schon.
Dann können die jetzt endlich mal im Jahr 2018 ankommen und Schweißtropfen-Physik einführen.
Hey, den kenne ich!
Endlich einen, den ich kenne!
Ich bin super gespannt, hier zu sein.
Wir machen diese Präsentation ein bisschen anders und geben euch euren ersten Blick
auf ein brandneues Mobile-Spiel in einem Live-Winner-Take-Off-Head-to-Head-Match.
Michael, erzähl uns die Regeln.
Sicher, das Ziel ist einfach.
Die Opponenten-Base zerstören, um zu gewinnen.
Die Kontrolle der Units ist super einfach.
Einfach auf die Destination klicken, die Units werden automatisch gewechselt.
Die Möglichkeit, die Opponenten-Base zu zerstören, ist mit diesem zentralen, nuklearen Missil in der Mitte des Maps.
Kontrolle der Missile.
Es ist Halo, es sieht aus wie Halo Wars.
Und Stalker aus Starcraft.
Mobile Game Esports.
Das ist aber ein richtiges Omega-Lol.
Da haben sie aber die ganze Starcraft-Leute abgezogen jetzt.
Seine Opponenten kämpfen für die rote Seite des Raumes.
Ein kompetitiver Mobile-Gaming-Phänomen.
Bitte begrüßen Sie mich in der Bühne, Nick at Night.
Den kenne ich nicht.
Kennt ihr ihn?
Kennt ihr Nick at Night?
Also in der Ständis und in Kontrolle kennen wir ihn wenigstens.
Die kompetitiven Hintergründe, die diese Spieler haben, sollten ein großartiges Match sein.
Total, das ist es wirklich.
Ich kann nicht warten.
Mobile Game Esports, das sieht immer so hängengeblieben aus.
Das sieht immer so hängengeblieben aus.
Wenn sie dann auf den Stuhl mit so einem Mini-Ding in der Hand sind.
Vor allem in Kontrolle ist er auch so ein riesen Typ.
In dem seine Hand zieht, sieht das Smartphone halt einfach mal aus wie nix.
Oh, ein Harvester wie ein CNC.
Das ist nicht so verrückt.
Nicht so verrückt.
Jetzt wird die Infanterie rauskommen, um das Smartphone zu halten.
Das ist ein Top-Point.
Beide Spieler versuchen natürlich, diese Position zu nehmen.
Nick at Night kann es ein bisschen zuerst erreichen.
In einer Strategie-Game, in dieser Flanken-Position.
Die Kontrolle geht von der Top-Seite.
Auch sehr wichtig.
Nick at Night ist so ein bisschen...
Oh, hier.
Hier kommt GDI mit einem Rhino.
Das wird die Infanterie rausnehmen.
Das ist kein Warthog, das ist ein Rhino.
Denkt dran, das ist ein Rhino.
Das ist ja auch nicht Halo Wars.
Ihr Mikromanagement eurer Kräfte und die Befreiung der Öffentlichkeit.
Nick at Night mit ein paar Attack-Bikes auf der Top-Seite.
Da ist er.
In Kontrolle, die Turret auf der Top-Rechte, um das Rhino zu schützen,
als die Attack-Bikes auf die Nordwest-Situation gehen.
Wir sehen, dass das Missil anfängt, sich zu vorbereiten und das zu schießen.
Das nimmt die Hälfte eurer Base.
Das wichtigste Ziel auf dem Spiel ist es, diese Räder zu halten.
In Kontrolle, die viel Erfolg machen, auf der weit rechten Seite des Spiels.
Er hat einen tollen Job gemacht, das mit der Turret zu machen.
Und jetzt redeployiert er seine Fahrzeuge auf der Südseite,
um mehr Infanterie zu bringen, um die Attack-Bikes zu schützen.
Und jetzt kommt die Rimside.
Da ist das halt so.
Da muss man halt die Mobile-Casual-Leute abschröpfen, so viel wie geht.
Ach so, Intens!
Intens!
Huge Place!
Massive!
Yellow Position.
Very important, of course, blocking the pathing of those units
is another big factor for this strategy.
Holding those locations is so crucial,
as in control begins to secure the Northwest spot.
Another tank's gonna come out from Nick at night to take it out.
But now he's bringing out the pitbull as well to help lock down that North position.
This missile is very, very close to firing.
Let's see what's gonna happen.
Ich brauch auf jeden Fall fürs nächste Mal noch das...
Face-Pom.
Wow!
Overlay.
Und...
Oh mein Gott!
Seid ihr auch schon so richtig so angespannt?
Seid ihr auch schon so quasi...
Also könnt ihr euch...
Also ich hab echt Probleme, hier sitzen zu bleiben.
Das ist ein kompletter Hype einfach nur.
Das ist ein kompletter Hype.
Das Game sieht doch noch so scheiße aus irgendwie.
Das ist bestimmt ein Unity-Game.
Sagt's euch, Leute.
Das ist ein Unity-Game.
Huge!
Massive Play, huge Damage.
Oh.
Okay.
Es ist fast schon 1 von 2.
Mal gucken, wie lange das Ganze geht.
Wow!
What's going on?
Das frage ich mich auch, ehrlich gesagt, schon die ganze Zeit.
There it is!
Defeating Naked Face 1.
That was epic.
Nice.
Oops.
Amazing.
What a match.
Thank you so much.
That was awesome.
Thank you.
Any thoughts, guys?
I just came to make Mammoth Tanks, so I've done my job.
Absolutely.
I've done a little bit of everything right there.
Perfect.
Let's hear it for Nathaniel.
A nice, great control.
Ladies and Gentlemen, what you just saw was the world-wide reveal of Command & Conquer
rivals.
Rivals reimagines the real time strategy experience for Modern Warfare.
For Modern Warfare.
Sie haben ja schon aus Dungeon Keeper so ein Mobiltrack gemacht, so ein absolutes Bullshit-Game und jetzt wahrscheinlich CNC dran.
Das mache ich gleich.
Kostet das was?
Moment, wo ist mein Tablet?
Das müssen wir gleich, das gucken wir gleich im Playstore.
Wie ist das Ding? CNC Rivals oder so, ne?
Gucken wir, was es kostet.
Gucken wir uns gleich an.
Free Alpha.
Über den Playstore.
Wo?
Ja, genau.
Wirst du nicht angeguckt, so nach dem Motto, Alter, ich trete dir jetzt voll in die Fresse.
Und dann geht man auf das Tablet.
Klick.
Ich gucke auch immer so aggressiv, wenn ich vor meinem Tablet sitze.
Was ist das?
Soll der aussehen wie Kane oder was?
Es tut weh, es tut weh, den Titel da drauf zu sehen.
Es tut weh, den Titel da drauf zu sehen.
Jetzt, bevor wir das Show mit einem spektakulären, epischen Anthem beenden, wollte ich ein paar letzte Dinge teilen.
Ich bin glücklich, dass ich mit einigen der meisten kreativen Menschen auf der Welt arbeiten kann.
Und auch assisted, auch
Spielen die Games?
haven you any combination life without your Теперь experiencing the licences that will make every woman He'll imagine her goodbye.
that we moved past the ground in the imperial state Übertragung von and refrain von all arise sie nicht zu denken.
dass sie nichtagem jobs und große kommentaren ordinance über die verbundb disposal plates über die gesellschaftsuppрип 270.000 sub opened funding?
Die letzten drei Jahre sind wir 왜 war das jüngerenenchöre an?
Die genetischen Gruppen.
Wir haben kreativer gel McCain gegeben und das sind dann aber die meisten Fleckwellen
dass was in es ist besteht und das world wide sleeperخ integrigning
und dass dies Erfahrungen sind, die eindeutig eure Leben verbessern.
Und so, sobald wir über all die Dinge nachdenken, die wir versuchen zu machen,
wissen wir, dass wir besser werden wollen und dass wir gute Spiele machen wollen.
Und so viel wie wir Spiele machen lieben und so viel wie du sie spielst,
gibt es etwas, das noch größer ist, was wir zusammen tun können.
Die Kraft dieser Gemeinschaft, wenn wir zusammenkommen, um großartige Dinge zu tun, ist tief.
Letztes Wochenende war das dritte Jahr unseres Play-to-Give-Programms,
in dem wir dem Weltbild zeigen, wie die Kraft des Spiels eine positive Kraft für sozialen Einfluss sein kann.
Millionen von euch haben in unseren Spielen neun in-Game-Challenges teilgenommen,
die Millionen von Stunden in Unterstützung des Play-to-Give-Programms gedauert haben.
Und um das zu feiern, haben wir insgesamt 1 Mio. Dollar an drei Charitien geteilt,
die unsere Vision für eine inklusivere Welt teilen.
Eine Welt, in der die Repräsentanten
Ich wollte es auf den Zettel schreiben, dass irgendwelche Charity-Ankündigungen kommen.
Das macht sich immer gut. Das macht sich immer gut.
Und wo Bullying und Exklusion nicht ein tägliches Thread sind.
Diese drei Organisationen, die Vereinigten Nationen, hier für sie,
passen den Nationalen Bullying Prevention Center,
schmücken das Label und alle Bullying-Organisationen.
Alle machen großartiges Arbeit und wir sind stolz, sie durch Play-to-Give zu unterstützen.
Vielen Dank für euren Unterstützung.
Ich habe auch mich.
Ich meine EA spendet da jetzt ja nicht, weil sie es so geil finden,
sondern weil es ein gutes Licht auf sie wirft.
Aber es ist nicht verkehrt. Also ich kann jetzt nichts dagegen sagen.
Oh, oh, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Das sind die drei.
Da bin ich gespannt drauf.
Man sieht halt vom Gameplay gar nichts, ne?
Da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Man hat halt nicht so wirklich da was jetzt von gesehen, ne?
Aber vielleicht zeigen sie jetzt was.
Ich werde einen tiefen Dive in Anthem machen.
Ich werde einige Mitglieder von Anthem bringen,
von der BioWare-Team, um mit uns zu sprechen.
Meine Damen und Herren,
bitte gebt ein herzliches Willkommen an Casey Hudson,
Mark Dera und Kathleen Rutzart.
Oh, wir machen jetzt wieder so ein Fake-Interview, oder?
Ja.
Das gibt so ein absolut nicht einstudiertes,
voll authentisches, reales Interview.
Und wir haben eigentlich schon mit Anthem gearbeitet, bevor ihr geflogen seid.
Ja, das stimmt.
Also, du weißt, es ist großartig, wieder da zu sein.
Es ist großartig, Games für BioWare-Fans zu machen.
Wir haben die besten Fans.
Es ist super faszinierend, um zu kombinieren.
Ich würde gerne einmal die Legitimität des Studios abhaken.
Und das ist das, wo es mit Anthem angefangen hat.
Man denkt einfach daran, was ist die Evolution eines BioWare-Games?
Und wir wollten einen ganz neuen Weltraum schaffen,
um Leute zu entdecken.
Ein ganz neuer Weltraum von Geschichte und Charakter.
Aber wir wollen auch,
dass wir etwas machen, das mehr dynamisch und lebendig ist.
Ein Spiel, das sich immer wieder verändert,
je nachdem, wann man zurückgekommen ist und es gespielt hat.
Wir wollten auch etwas machen,
wo du, wenn du deine Freunde einladen willst,
dann kannst du das auch machen.
Also, das war wirklich die frühere Vision des Spiels.
Nicht ein MMO, nicht ein Multiplayer-Spiel,
mit einer Geschichte auf dieser Seite,
sondern etwas Neues und anderes.
Und ich denke, das Team hat diese Vision in den letzten Jahren erzeugt.
Deine Fans lieben wirklich die Geschichten von BioWare.
Aber ich denke, wir sind ein bisschen gespannt,
wie du planierst,
wie die Geschichte in diesem gemeinsamen Weltraum funktioniert.
Also, eine großartige Geschichte für BioWare
ist wirklich um Charaktere,
mit denen du eine Verbindung haben kannst.
Die Geschichte in Destiny war scheiße.
Und ich fühle mich, als ob die Geschichte über dich ist.
In einigen anderen Spiels werden diese Dinge
abgelöst,
weil du Multiplayer-Spiel und Geschichte in dieselben Bereichen mischst.
Du kannst eine Lösung dafür bauen,
aber du musst es wirklich in das Kern des Spiels bauen.
Und das ist es, was wir mit Anthem versucht haben.
Das ist, was wir unsere Welt, meine Geschichte nennen.
Also, wenn du...
Wenn du im offenen Weltraum bist,
ist der Weltraum wirklich gefährlich
und du bist auf deiner Mission konzentriert.
Und das ist, wo andere Spieler mit dir spielen können.
Das, was wirklich interessant ist,
was für Anthem einzigartig ist,
ist, dass das ein lebender, gemeinsamer Weltraum ist.
Also, egal ob es Wetter ist,
oder es ist Nachtzeit,
was wir erleben...
Ja klar, es sind dafür gescriptete Leute.
... alle, die Anthem spielen,
sehen im Moment das gleiche.
Und das ist, was wir bedeuten, wenn wir über unsere Welt sprechen.
Es ist ein gemeinsamer Weltraum, den wir alle zusammen erleben.
Aber dann, wenn ich meine Mission beendet habe,
komme ich zurück zu einer Basis, wie zum Beispiel Fort Tarsis.
Und das ist eine Singleplayer-Erfahrung.
Ich schalte meine Rewards ein.
Ich spreche mit ein paar Charakteren.
Ich erlebe die Auswirkungen...
Iron Man und Jeets bei Punkt Norden.
... und das ist, wo deine Geschichte wirklich lebt und lebt.
Und indem wir das so machen,
können wir die Anwendung einer Singleplayer-Story kombinieren
mit der Freude,
die du mit deinen Freunden teilen kannst,
um in Kampf zu spielen.
Und wir designen es auch so,
dass wir die Geschichte für die kommenden Jahre zusammensetzen können.
Eine der ersten Dinge, die wir von unseren Gemeinschaften hören,
ist, dass sie in unseren Welten weiter spielen wollen,
wenn sie Mass Effect oder Dragon Age beendet haben.
Spieler wollen mehr Geschichte.
Und deshalb haben wir Anthem so designt,
dass wir die Geschichte für die kommenden Jahre zusammensetzen können.
Und das kann alles sein.
Ein neuer Moment mit einem Charakter, den du lieben hast,
oder ein Event in der Welt, das tief in die Geschichte geht,
oder eine völlig neue Story und Plot.
Dass man in der bestehenden Welt neue Geschichten schreiben kann,
ist jetzt ja nicht so, dass es nur EA kann.
Kannst du zu dem sprechen,
was es ist, eine neue Welt wie Anthem von Anfang an zu schaffen?
Was für uns wirklich spannend ist,
und nicht nur für die Schriftsteller,
sondern für alle Devs, die Designer, die Schriftsteller,
ist, dass wir etwas Neues und Mysteriöses für die Spieler in der Welt kreieren.
Also, das ist der Grund für die Prämisse,
dass der Anthem in der Welt wird, unbeendet von den Göttern.
Aber die Götter haben ihre massiven Geräte hinterlassen.
Und diese Geräte sind in kontextuellem Konflikt
mit dieser unkennbarsten Kraft, die Anthem der Kreation heißt.
Und das Chaos, das diese Dinge gegen einander drücken,
bedeutet, dass die Welt ständig in neuen und unbedeutenden Wegen wiederentwickelt wird.
Sie fliegen einfach nur rum, man sieht überhaupt nichts vom Game.
Das alles Interessante sieht man von Konzeptart,
vor allem Early-Konzeptart des Games.
Wie lange ist das schon in der Entwicklung?
Drei Jahre, vier Jahre, ewig.
Pass mal auf, es läuft schon ein paar Mal weiter.
Es läuft schon ein paar Mal weiter.
Man muss doch was vom Game irgendwie zeigen können.
Keiner hat eine Ahnung von dem Game so richtig.
Und jetzt hätte man die Chance, quasi den Leuten mal was Geiles zu zeigen.
Aber man macht irgendwie ein auswendig gelerntes Interview.
Easy Clap.
Nein, ich glaube nicht wirklich, dass es eingestellt wird.
Aber ich meine, die müssen doch irgendwas zu zeigen haben.
Man, alles Interessante sieht man auf Konzeptart.
Und zwischendurch sieht man, das haben wir schon mal gesehen.
Zeig doch mal was vom Game.
Das haben wir auch schon gesehen.
Das ist noch mal das Gleiche.
Was? Ich habe irgendwas eingeschaltet im VLC.
Random on.
They discovered a way, they think, to weaponize the Anthem of creation.
And so we need to stop them and protect the free people of Tarsus.
Now, I've heard you call this power armor a couple different things.
Is it a suit? Is it a javelin?
Like, what's the canon term here?
We call them javelins, and there are four.
And they each have unique abilities.
There's the ranger.
And then there's the colossus.
The interceptor.
And finally...
The storm.
Yeah, so, each javelin gives you a different way to play the game.
But the thing to remember is, like Kathleen said, you're not your suit.
You are a freelancer, a pilot.
Which means you can decide which suit you want to use based on your mood,
based on the mission you want to engage in,
or the javelins that your friends are using.
So, really what this allows us to do is,
we built the suits to look like they're built from the material...
Das Problem ist halt so ein bisschen, die erzählen uns quasi Details vom Game,
ohne dass man irgendwie eine Ahnung davon hat.
Oh, man sieht was.
Auto-Aim.
Der Colossus ist schwerer, mehr spezialisiert,
aber er kann wirklich große Waffen machen, die die Schiffe zerstören.
I'm just going to say, the storm looks like it's going to be my favorite
and I'm sure you guys out there are picking your favourite now, too.
So, the javelins look awesome,
Aber wir werden jetzt ein paar Fragen stellen. Casey hat getwittet, wie man vielleicht gesehen hat,
und fragt die Leute, um ihre Fragen zu stellen.
Und der erste ist von Atitsweet Nicole, die fragt,
als Spieler, der sich um seinen eigenen Charakter kümmert,
welche Kustomisierungsoptionen in Anthem vorhanden sein werden?
Ja, das ist auch...
Das ist das Erste, was mich interessiert in dem Game, wisst ihr?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, um was es in dem Game geht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie sich das Game spielt.
Ich weiß ja nicht mal so richtig, in welchem Genre das ist.
Ich weiß überhaupt nichts über das Game.
Aber meine erste Frage ist natürlich,
liebe Entwickler, sagt mir mal, was wird es denn für Kustomisations geben?
Also, das bedeutet, dass die Leute sich über etwas freuen, was selbstverständlich sein sollte.
War es halt die letzten Jahre nicht.
Also, das bedeutet, dass die Hauptgeschichte, ein großer, offenes Welt,
und ein weitergehendes Service, das neue Inhalte für einen langen Zeitraum bietet.
Neue Geschichte, neue Erfahrungen für alle.
Na, ich bin froh, dass ich meinen Javelin pink machen kann.
Das ist wirklich alles, was ich wissen wollte.
Ich werde es annehmen.
Okay, Casey.
Wir haben vorhin gesprochen.
Wann soll es erscheinen?
Moment, es gibt ja schon ein Release-Datum.
2019, okay.
Also langweilig.
Da kann man ein neues Game nicht anpreisen.
Oh ja.
Ja, wie wärs damit?
Gute Idee nach 20 Minuten Gelaber.
Gameplay.
Haben sie das Model aus Battlefront genommen,
wollen wir heute für die
Spielzeit platziert.
Die Musik ist übelst
laut.
Ja, sag ich doch.
Range-DD,
Range-Caster, Support und Tank.
So in der Richtung.
Es ruckelt ein bisschen.
Ja, das ruckelt.
Das ruckelt.
Cinematic Experience ist das.
Leute, es ruckelt nicht.